nancy pelosi doubting president trump's
mental fitness
after his copit 19 diagnosis now the
speaker is talking about taking
drastic measures against him what i
don't know what the prospects are
when we hear people saying i'm i'm young
and i'm a perfect perfect specimen
come here tomorrow we're going to be
talking about the 25th amendment
but not to take attention away from the
subject we have now do you think it's
time to invoke the 25th amendment
i'll talk to you about that tomorrow
i'll talk to you about it tomorrow i'm
not talking about it today except to
tell you
if you want to talk about that we'll see
you tomorrow president is firing back
tweeting quote
crazy nancy is the one who should be
under observation they don't call her
crazy for nothing
um oh gosh is this like an episode of
veep or what
i i just i don't even know what to do um
she
says she doesn't want to talk about it
then she teases come back tomorrow to
talk about it
ensuring that everyone's going to talk
about it who does she remind you of
donald trump yeah she has learned from
the master
if you want to knock out real news all
you got to do
is make up some of your own because she
she's learned that like trump played
cnn like just like a violin right he
just knew that he could just get
he could just eat up all the time she's
doing that with us what did we have on
this block before we had the russia
collusion probably one of the biggest
cover-ups in the history of cover-ups
that destroyed so many institutions
undermine the media
undermine the fbi and we kicked it out
for this story
it's freaking brilliant what she did and
it's almost i mean it's like that's what
you can't blame her you could almost
kind of admire her for it well i think
the fact is what you get here is
she gets under trump's skin like nobody
just do what trump did yeah but i think
i think she's in some ways genius
because she's trolling trump
i think i think just like when she said
you guys trump shouldn't
trump shouldn't have uh a debate biden
shouldn't bother to debate trump because
trump lies so much i think
it just got under trump's skin and i
think by the way
to the substance of it there's a real
possibility
that you know the drugs and things that
trump is taking because of his illness
is impacting and making him i mean why
would anybody say no more talks about
helping them what do you think
i mean it's really anything different
yeah i mean that's that's the thing
katie i don't i don't know if i
i don't see that is there a 25th
amendment for the speaker of the house
is there like something similar that
they can invoke to try and
make sure that nancy pelosi is also in
her right mind the big news tomorrow she
wants you to tune in for is they are
going to announce
the establishment of a commission on
presidential capacity because
that's exactly what the house should be
focusing on right now
another commission in washington dc
which i'm sure will solve all of the
problems that she wants
that is an old trick when you can't get
coronavirus relief bill passed after you
start a commission on something
sure it'll be a lot like the
presidential debate commission very fair
and balanced this is the exactly what
greg said they're trying to take the
wind out of pence's sales because he
mopped the floor with comics oh my gosh
juan everybody agrees this is nobody
lost and you lost heart
why are they keep distracting us with
25th amendment and
changing it to a virtual debate maybe he
was trying to get out of the good
debates
because he saw what happened and i also
tell you what the pence
they have to this took a bite out of the
virus in terms of public perception the
fact that the president's recovered
and he's ready to get back out there so
quickly so they have to say
you're crazy mr president for recovering
for being healthy and for wanting to get
back out on the campaign trail
because coronavirus that's a death
sentence and the fact that you recovered
like that
and are telling seniors that regeneron
is on the way
we have to undermine that because you
must be crazy yeah i would agree he must
be crazy
you know the best thing about this hour
yes fastest